today on our show we got a guest man ah
yes this was a show called fat man I
Batman we predicated on comic books and
we never talk about that we're talking
about comic books
we got man's responsible to be tired
young animal line as well as your entire
childhood go to a three-shot show salt
jarred wait what is here I'm Sam man on
Batman hi
that men on Batman talks about navnav
difference behind log Bernard Annette
look it's Gerard Way ladies and
gentlemen the leader of the Black Plague
Gerard is not here talking about music
say although Gerard was in this very
room one two years ago three years ago
we did this amazing podcast if you ever
want to hear some ear candy if you
haven't heard already we did an episode
where we took welcome to The Black
Parade a man's butt literally broke it
down yeah like lime for one you know al
you listen to music and you go like oh
man like I always wanted I wonder what
this means I wonder what this means why
they include that we turned into two
episodes yeah I think so for a song you
know granted four minutes in change
maybe three yeah I think I think well I
used to totally know but I think it's
like four and a half but there's a radio
and if it's like over a half I think and
we turned it into like a multi-episode
podcast just diving deep into some but
here we are this time once again in this
living room and now it's the faculty and
we're looking at see this what go it go
to a single see this go to for our
simple see this see from all angles look
at the quotes on the back [ __ ] famous
people of [ __ ] all whom were approving
this is the first six issues of Gerard's
Doom Patrol run Gerard is editing what
he called I'm like a kind of like a
mercurial I'm telling a showrunner all
young animal we have two great editors
they do the book of the other narratives
Molly may han and jr h promoting yeah
didn't really notice I was legit you got
a bonafide folks young animal is the
line of comics that right now is Doom
Patrol shave a changing girl another
panic mode panic Yuko pre yes I'm a
character yes with Jodie Hauser and
Tommy Lee Edwards and you sucker the
character in Gotham yeah cause it just
felt like could be a cool place for this
category was it started as like a
creator own thing in my head and then I
was like at you know and also it's like
why not why why not own something in
gospel yeah but that'd be cool smart
real estate is really it was awesome to
watch and then what's the other Kate
Carson has a seven
guy genius title Gerard is deep comics
if you don't know this but you worked in
actual comic book store I did I worked
in a comic shop and that's about 14 15
and this is can you imagine this kid the
kid who worked with the comic book store
is this guy now he's writing group story
reading frame horse I were on my
afternoon now I want those three grants
and then into Rachel [ __ ] from and I
had a really cool friend with the my
friend Scott he was the first guy I met
in the comic shop and he he turned me on
all the really hip stuff like flaming
carrot do Patrol and Reese leveraging
the world of his milk man's and we're
the shirt kids you know we were all the
shirt kids you have to Congress I think
I was wearing a watchman shirt when I
met him and then it just Kenya went on
from there
we talked about it I'm on the other
podcast but something somewhat have you
come oh yeah I actually just talked
about to say see so there was a robbery
and we were held up at gunpoint and I
was in Florida took the gun of my head
you know
I appreciated the way more scared that I
was but um yeah I'm glad I didn't die so
yeah every one of a massive career and
music and then one day how did this
happen then happened because I do want
to do it for a really long time and some
time after Braille Academy came out I
met up with Shelly bond who is a vertigo
at who helped me start young animal and
we immediately we're talking about do
patrol and then kind of back and forth
the know the right time so those always
in the band and we were touring
everywhere constantly and I did write
like seven pages of it once and send it
off to her and that was kind of a very
cynical version of it and then years
later when I talked to her again and I
talked to Dan ABEO and Jim Lee about the
imprint I knew I definitely wanted to do
patrol and but it felt like it needed
some friends with it it felt like you
couldn't just put that out on its own we
needed some kind of contact so that's
why we came up with the other books and
career the kind of universities yeah
like a mini university you know and I
think one of the things we'll probably
get to see this year and maybe next year
is is some kind of shared universe of
some sorts or at least the books like
touching upon each other you know one of
the things that's what I'm so Veronica
yeah you know
to recession ami together the erotic his
young animal yeah they do deliver what
we came up the name yeah I did it was
namely the name of my second solo album
but this is a project I wanted to do
instead of making music at the time so I
just use that name for it here's my
question the when when you walk in
you're like I want to write Doom Patrol
natural ensure to like yay
but when you're like I wanna write to
the trunk and I have three other books
they're attached to if I'm going over
see the appropriate easing
what do they say that moment yes oh my
god this is going well it was like it
was just really kind of natural you know
I've been friends with Jim Lee for years
like he was there like in England with
his wife and and we were playing Black
Parade and you know we've been friends
and I met Dan adiy and I really liked
him and so we had there was this
convention in South America we were all
there and which sends up having dinner
like multiple nights in her own all
talking and I got to dinner with Frank
Miller and it was really cool
Gabrielle Fabio were there it was just a
good time so we came back and I feel
like it was less than a week later we
were sitting talking about what to do
next and when at what point was your
inner child still hovering dude and then
after the inner child that was like man
be nice to be a rock star
and now you're serving and her child is
like man be nice to you have license
books yeah so yeah but he did it with
umbrella cut it's not even like your
first day at the races and stuff right
you got to taste put your front end D
because knowing umbrella cab news okay
it's a one-shot you're like you keep
going on you had a life to that what was
the other book
Dallas was the second part of the
Umbrella Academy and then there was the
true lives of the Fabulous Killjoys Hill
director Oh with Sean Simon and who now
does tons of books and you know he he
did our top with Michael read and he's
just a really talented writer a great
friend you are entrenched in comics
world and have them yeah forever this
point yes what is the ultimate dream
obviously this is dream come true
because you're working on he loved his
book and you get to yeah well I worked
on dating I love trying to run and I was
like I'll never be able to do it but let
me play in that universe yeah I don't
really handling on a bucket list things
less like this is kinda
if you scrape to the bottom of the yeah
I like I've done really everything oh
and I like to ride in unicorn
yeah exactly
well you and also I imagine got the
freedom one you do if you do crossovers
when you cross overs but you'll get to
play with don't you probably care if you
want no I think it's cool there is Li
good there is so it's not Wonder Woman
not this yeah they're characters that's
we get along I couldn't really dream ago
in there and I think that's good like
part of what I was hoping to bring with
the imprint TDC was like this ability to
kind of take some lesser known
characters or like deal if characters or
just characters that have been around
since the 60s and do something with them
so I think it's kind of one of my you
know my role there did you talk about
the the fourth any fourth chemical town
will spawn this in Berlin that I know we
talked about Twitter sugar gander well
I'll mark like a future book we're all
like if we're developing them right now
me and the editors are kind of doing
that and we're getting approvals and
seeing where things go like I don't know
when we'll make an announcement so stuff
but we do have bug which first six-issue
miniseries for young you know by the
l-word family and sort of the orbit yeah
that allows is Mike and Bora Mike Lee
Laura yeah Lee right at Lisa's brother I
think younger brother and Mike drop it
and lower colors it
oh my lord yeah yeah it's awesome and
it's it's the Kirby characters foregin
yes I'm a reader in cosmic gorgeous yeah
mo yes introduction with a because in
that first page in issue one is actually
a couple callbacks to cosmic Odyssey
panels oh my god doesn't do cook yeah he
as well the are ed family goes very deep
deep cut for them what have you done
with him so far did they do anything
thus far with you I did I see you in
connects with them have they done all
good I just been a fan for years and I
am I wrote like an afterword but it
would it was it called in RAM rocket 7 I
wrote like me afterwards it was a dog or
something was called something news
related and I'd been a fan for years and
I did that and he did this illustration
of me in the band which he gifted to me
after that so I I've always wanted to
work with him so now can you get to I
did
he designed font man and chronics oh he
did he did when you did a chasing amy
using the opening of chasing the image
so - yeah yeah I remember his scene he
has like it's like a cut - and it's him
delivering a line doing it was like I
just don't see I like somebody some
actor because I just don't see him
playing man man hey over here the actor
was ah all right so I've been talking
[ __ ] booster dubbin coming how you
sort of put together the teams for these
books and what were you looking for
building the creative Oh dancing yeah
well I was looking for it I was looking
for people that really want to be
something different really wanted to
tell human stories I think that was
important um and and and that was like
the main thing I people that Brian
Bolland covers yes that was pretty
amazing huh
people that kind of understood the world
we were going to share and create
together just people with great ideas
you know that was big part of it and
people that would really care about
these books as if they were their
creator own books which is kind of a
unique thing with young animal all the
creators feel I feel it no no no no but
it you know the kind of a work yeah the
kind of work people are doing on these
very personal with them you know because
they like the courage over the back
which is where they go back with them
and in the case of Jody housing she
co-created mother panic so it's partly
hers as well and and you know they even
go back with the characters run it's not
the first ones like the 90s runs like
Milligan doing shade and moves like that
so yeah that was my year ago that's rose
knee-deep in a meeting and the air a
bittersweet believe that I like left
behind when I got busy doing something
else and you saw the stack of comics
next to you first it started as sad
comments on your desk I got to read
these Nick this week and then the pile
would get bigger and bigger and then the
problem moot support and then was just
all at the desk and I realized I'm never
going to be semi like it's over I'm not
caught up unlawfully so something like
young M on something like this book
which comes out tomorrow Tuesday to nob
that you jump on at this point this is
the first six issues abuse yes that's a
perfect that's the first chapter and so
you're going to be releasing first six
of
other three titles as well at least yeah
and they come out
I think July is I know shade is in
August so July believes mother panting
Cape Carson
what's hard to run song run come well
I'm writing a comment um it's longer I
think writing I don't writing in general
like is just this like you start to kind
of understand why people have such a
hard time with it when you really sit
down to seriously do it all the time
and you know it's a solitary thing it's
kind of alienating like yeah look at me
I've got Jesus I remember Laurie Ellis
talking about the way he writes he
writes comics suspicious English's as if
there's talks there are rock songs like
for him it's very rhythmic it's very
yeah yeah chorus verse chorus uh-huh B
section like something big is about to
happen being a little bit of Ben you
want to set up the next song that looks
oh I totally see that yeah I could see
it being like that and the times where I
was really hitting a wall I would kind
of rely on the skills I've learned as a
songwriter and make things very lyrical
so you know that's cool that other
people are you know have been doing that
and also these kids like you get to you
get to actually bend reality so yeah I
never want to come so my god you can't
you can you can't write yourself into a
corner because somebody goes first to a
wall it's very true yeah jobs
particularly you get characters that
aren't even like I saw Justice League
you know this invention somewhat yeah
they have superpowers and act in a
certain way but these characters are far
flung from the beaten path that means
like you know as you're sitting there
riding feel like oh my god what do I do
you could just do the most [ __ ]
outlandish thing you know like what
that's do in control yeah and sometimes
it's kind of what you have to do you
know this is an amazing learning
experience and my partner on the book
Nick Darrington
he's just been so amazing so
hard-working you know Tamra Bond villain
is the colorist and she's just done an
amazing job Todd Klein's was fluttering
like but you know it really is like this
unique team and everybody has a
different kind of role in operation and
it's kind of like Tamra kind of comes at
the end real fast and just colors
everything you know and which feels like
she's asleep
like like 48 hours wait mommy we just
keeps getting pages from her and and
Nick really he just grinds constantly
drawing and you know I'm not the fastest
scripter and he can pencil pretty fast
and then when we when we have Tom come
in Tom fell recovering - it's cool -
because he's great you know it captures
Nick's pencils really well but you know
Nexus did like we definitely share a
brain and he's an amazing guy and I'm
really glad to have met him yeah there
are a lot of I could not but notice a
lot of female creators that you have
sort of working on the line was that by
design was that a happy action except
there's two people but the best ideas
one um I mean you know people will often
say you know like the best ideas usually
win but at the same time I think
perspective too went out - you know it's
not only do we want people that were I
mean you know number one like they're
absolutely the most talented people to
be writing those two books but they also
have a woman's perspective which both of
those books really needed especially
like you know shade is a 15 well she's
got 20 something in a 60 year old girl's
body like I don't know how to write that
you know that might be okay but if L
version become be written brought out in
a suitable there's a version but like
Cecil pesto Lucci her writing us is like
that's kind of her world like why a
fiction and you know comics and things
like t2 this great book called the plain
James with Jim rug way back when minx
was an imprint that Shelly bond created
DC and so she had you know so Cecil has
this real history with writing those
kinds of stories and really capturing
kind of like the the aggression and the
angst of of those years you know so you
know it's [ __ ] amazing did you would
you walk the walk with you absolutely
tuck the top where you can talk and you
know comics I love I you know Ibiza I
don't know a lot I like super deep comic
knowledge but you just you can drop
names of people that worked on the ocean
oh yeah I've been around in a minute
where I'm like oh [ __ ] I get it oh yeah
I guess yeah I guess I yeah I'm really
horrible with names to those so allotted
a damn
I'm doing great how about fan an account
book reader yes one one becomes kind of
writer what happens to read yeah they're
eating kinda goes away
do you ever speak before you dive in the
ears like I what was i working on I was
working on a show but W uh one of those
animation thing seventeen that [ __ ] but
before I would sit down to write I would
watch Rick and Morty because I was like
nah cuz I'm like I gotta make electric
more than I'm right if this is this
makes my business creatively fertile
this me I go on holy [ __ ] like that if
that's possible what else is possible it
is a creative for His grace not done
that you like to remind well this is
actually what I do if a few years have
gone by since I last wrote a comic and
I'm kind of reengaged I'll go to comic
shop and I'll just kind of get
everything it looks cool out there and
I'll make sure I don't do anything like
those but and you know I'd like to know
what exists out there for people you
know um so and and I end up you know
like both proof coughing I found that
way I was like well this looks really
good and I love the book you know um so
I like to do that I like to kind of see
without there and what I would like to
see that's missing you know cuz some
people sometimes they're making really
great stuff that you want to see
I'll follow you on Instagram and you
have one of those accounts where you'll
put up it's very artistic you put up an
image of a color there's an image of a
cup oh yeah I remember when we were
talking about that numbers in a while if
you what you don't do the normal life
yeah yeah I'm putting this famous [ __ ]
like text it's Archie yeah I don't we
are two words just like oh man this is
too hot for me yeah it's it's no it's
not no it's really quite beautiful and
you can draw I can draw I guess I didn't
go to school visual arts ninety
graduates SVA SVA yeah what what it is
there ever a moment where you're like oh
no if I could do it interior or even a
content covers have you done going
undercover is wrong I get a killjoys
cover nothing for this yet I think I was
so busy with the script and nobody even
suggested it to me my job exactly you
know this guy's got enough going on with
brain can you listen to music when
you're right I'm so they I thought
because I talk about this all the time I
can't listen to music and I could listen
to pretty much any music but recently I
stopped listening to music with lyrics I
I know a lot of people that write
general just when you wrote um in
general mostly um but when I write
almost always you know I wish I could
remember half the stuff but I'll be like
soundtracks official gallon it's like a
sound recordings jana win durin i love
she does these really create sound
recordings where i believe she like go
to the arctic and she'll just kind of
record the sound of that and it was what
mergers or some ways i know yeah it's
like kind of really textured
interesting white noise what does it do
that was by talking weeds now it really
nate'll it helps me focus it's like a my
friend Jamie calls them brain cleansers
yeah and there's this uh Robert Sherman
has this record called flux and should
tape loops and it really does clean your
brain in some weird way calls for flux
that one's flux but Gina when Duran was
like I listened to her albums constantly
um energy sphere out of view
here's something great such a sound
critics I mean I'm sure she says
something because I how awesome random
sound that's what you have to check them
out they're really amazing there is a
one-hour long loop on YouTube just of
the Enterprise bridge noise oh it's
literally just people are so wonderfully
[ __ ] - oh I'm sorry that's how I work
this is what I knew that's how I work
about Telecom either way our circuit
bridge noise we're going to get anywhere
right now I want to like go into my
thing but I do but I just want to tell
you what you know there's some really
cool stuff with some of the monkeys
without weird or a friend like more
importantly hey hey with a month money
like that we are on a journey man rustic
like Garfield I'm George
Gerard aside from doing like I was
saying like such a parameter capture so
we're looking for yeah change it you see
a Jatin RMA and I think what he does he
doesn't aquariums where he'll take like
a he'll take like a recording device and
like hang it on telephone wires or like
some kind of cables and get the
vibrations from so it's been birdie
should on the highway far away yeah
probably a little bit like that yeah
exactly because that's how we go yeah or
if you do two of them aside from My
Chemical Romance and whatnot I I turn I
asked one day first very like simply and
not thinking we could do it but ask
Gerard to record a song for the end of
test yeah which is like like one of my
favorite things in the [ __ ] world
there's a song was I mean the water is
wide that water is wildly cool but it's
a face style
I don't know that official title yeah
there's some old lolly wolly is that it
okay so I want to do the waters wide but
you would have to pay for it but it was
based on Oh Wally Wally so they were
like just go back to the source so
Gerard did that and then went even a
step further and composed his own and
the history of that song is such that
someone has lyrics someone at a yeah it
expands it was actually kinda good but
it is hauntingly [ __ ] beautiful more
beautiful is more beautiful than that
movie has a right it felt like when I
put it on the movie I was like this it's
such a beautiful song it's being killed
by this this rubber walrus backing of it
with these horrible noises and then like
this miracle angel comes in that things
is like heartbreaking like love song one
of the only and granted I'm close to it
because I love the movie stuff but one
of the only like love songs that truly
will make my eyes well it's and it not
because the lyrics but you put into that
one moment where you're like to love to
love a girl that breaks my always
[ __ ] perfect so for that and we threw
it in that plug I was like we're going
to win an Oscar nobody did but he should
for that [ __ ] song Larkin awesome the
word I could not believe see right here
Artie I could not believe it existed
after I want to I could not believe it I
made another methanol and I still can't
[ __ ] believe it but that was that
that was like me trying to be r2 stuff
like that that's why I was so awesome to
have you involved too because it was
like he's our societal balance board I
remember attending I was watching it in
your office and then it ended and it
held on that shot where the song would
have been and I was like I have to do
this [ __ ] crazy big black spot this
is like a [ __ ] I don't want to do my
career anymore this would be the perfect
way to end it go out with this walrus
song yeah I want to get to comics as
quickly as possible
mmm-hmm I'm not going to ask the music
or comics that they're both seem horses
of the same of color but which is a more
visually interesting world to be in now
big people answer because in your videos
and your concerts like it wasn't just
like hey we showed up and we said there
was a presentational event yeah let's
chain of them so Chad what and but this
is a world as I'm writing and then it's
going to turn into pictures you are
surrounded by visual switches more
visible I'm just trying to see one more
promote but there are people in both
narrative to me symbol three nads the
visual language of both music and comics
are that way but I they're they're both
so strong in different ways like
something that you could you can't
really do in music and usually you can
conjure an image in somebody's hat or
you can dress yourself up a certain way
and then convey an image as well you can
have stuff running behind you but in
comics you can you can create an image
and put a certain combination of words
on that to create something happening in
your brain you know and you can't do
that with music um so so at times yeah
they just have different strengths comic
comic can be super impactful visually um
and what it's doing at braylin BSO can
music when you guys
when did you realize hey we're going to
make this a visually interesting band
presentation as opposes just we're going
to jam I think it's because of my comic
background I think it was a matter of
time and I think if I didn't
you know if the guys weren't so as cool
to let me do that stuff with the band I
think I went crazy I would have been so
bored of like just being in like t-shirt
jeans like rocking out what what but
yeah I'm so happy you did but why why
like did you feel like [ __ ] songs are
too good
like why are we going to wear jeans and
t-shirts was [ __ ] dress around it was
smelling that for sure but again it was
like it didn't exist at that point now
there have been a lot of people like for
many years doing that for anything Alice
Cooper and David Bowie you know there's
like window world there is enough I
wanted to see that I was like how come
nobody does this anymore and I was like
cool we can do it we'll do it you know
and that was silly again it goes back to
like let me see what's out here and then
they're just like nothing that I really
want so I want to do that let's do it
seems to be the mantra view [ __ ] much
we can do that yeah we can do that if I
go in Jersey collaboratively like that's
been you know the amazing thing about
all the projects you know going back
from the banners like you get to work
and make art with people and collaborate
together and it's just amazing like
everybody on young animal like we do you
know collaborate more so in the
beginning you know because everybody's
just in their own world now and they're
doing it and that's all I ever want to
do again well like your Jodi Houser
doing amazing things with love it panic
and and it's her just such a different
book than the other ji-yong animal and I
think that's why it's so important
beyond young animal and then give John
Rivera who is he's my buddy from art
school yeah yeah laughs yeah we meant
comedy writing class and we were only
two people made sure laughs and it was
you know and then we became really close
friends stayed in touch but he's a comic
artist writer and I knew he was going to
understand cave Carson I just do it like
I had a book in my hand and I was like
John we'll get it I don't know if
anybody else is good how is the book
received on the home front am a lady is
our chief art yes
she's gettin art shows you know lemon I
went for her art show at at La Luz the
hizzouse
soap factory and Talia and she did she
did this piece which I bought in his in
Hartley's room
she took her old journal pieces yeah
this really amazing oh my god was
fencing yeah yeah that's why I had to
buy them there was one you're talking
she took her old journal pieces and then
she did art on top of them so like the
one journal page with the art on it that
I bought was her going like I must be a
star so bad like all the compliments of
teenage youth a nags going like this
will happen and she did so I kind of
like wonderfully self passive so how did
she react to open was she comments that
she loved it she was and now it's well
she got into comics from 8-ball and
that's kind of her kind of common words
I think she likes the real arty kind of
great and they're great books - I'm a
big fan of that stuff - Dan Clowes you
know and everything but you know that
that's kind of her experience of comics
has been those books and then you know
she started reading mine she obviously
is a big supporter and she loves them
but you know she was really psyched on
this one I think she was most excited
about Jean showing up I think that was a
character that I had a feeling she was
going to like her I think some in some
small ways I kind of probably based some
of her on Lindsay so smart man yeah
Marvin you're like research via likeness
is there a feeling when you're when
you're running an imprint like that it
it seems to be a little bit like running
a band you know in that like a so many
people who all have it
yeah heel into town on whatever they it
to be like lead singer later right right
that was that part of the initiative
behind young animal like what you would
left My Chemical Romance oh I don't know
that you well I don't know that they
were related but it definitely you know
it definitely gave me kind of the skills
or the ability to be able to recognize
when I felt like something was like
others who perfect for what we're doing
like this person gets it you know
and that's that is what you do when
you're starting a band you you're like
you you know you look at your friends or
maybe people you don't know and you say
who gets it like I get it who gets it
the same way as I do and so that did
carry right over into young animal who's
your rippln the videos I did one and a
half well I I directed the trailer that
came out for killjoys I co-directed
not aa and I cook
act and say do you ever want to go to
future you run other stuff now do the
it's weird I got a good up well you
waited me as a set that time thank you
and for come on I had a blast
like that was that was my first time
being able to watch like a film being
shot and it was really cool after the
troop of music leaders yeah oh yeah well
it was yeah it was it was just amazing
experience and I was like I'm ready for
this uh-huh you are do that at the end
of the day it's like it seems like
that's what it's building towards like
you've got public performance down in
science and now you've got storytelling
you got storytelling mayor down design
storytelling here down the side you have
directed music video yeah combine them
all together look I think any yeah I
think eventually that would be something
you know I'd be really interested in
what would it take what if they were
like you know what we got 100 million
we'll let you did you a patrol movie I
would totally do it don't ever be like
I've done enough just I 100%
I will seem very even I like comics
really want one of my I have two mediums
that I love and comics and music and and
writing falls into the middle of those
but I would definitely do that in our
bead but if I get everybody on the
creative team of the comic to work on it
with me in the world was over 200
million yeah that's a small ass when we
get off he's working for a hundred fifty
bucks a page break all the way I'm gonna
have like Nick creating all the concept
art we have Tamara guiding doing color
guides for everybody doing no they have
to be kind of like real not how we did
Watchmen with it I think they had they
were basing colors off direct panels
please look well yeah but actually other
shows yeah he was really into getting it
super accurate but no movie any
turnaround like would be be us if there
is still references to watchman there
was a who watches the Watchmen half an
hour late scribbled somewhere with an
inlet chromatic I figure we'll see what
is it quick quick sip so I used to melt
at one point that's a hard core work did
you ever buy remember the Dave Gibbons
they like DC put out the watchman covers
in black and white and you could frame
them suitable for frames I know in time
that
add that about them on a secondary
market when I got some money one day I
could never afford him when I was
Trufant threat to court city marijuana
bang bong I did have the West End game
with RPG source book of law that was a
very popular and expense yaker one for
hey well yeah and I lost it a little
early I know could you believe I lost
that book I bought it in the meddler for
the price it was physical I don't know I
was like it's a pretty sick I mean I
moved around from you know no I lost
this like years ago I probably lost it
as a relationship or not the figure of
rosebud do you like [ __ ] ball season
that well i brocades done I retain
almost all the information product cuz I
read it a million times
oh man one more and Dave Gibbons has
something to do with that boat and
there's information about like
silhouettes that you would never get in
the comic like there's information to
all of them and it's like you know if
you can find what it's almost extended
universe then it's from from masters
from the guy from the people that made
the thing do tell ya the bonus material
for a cop it is it was my first
experience with bonus material what book
did I see recently film oh I think it
was graffiti might have done it they did
a Dark Knight book that was sourced to
the original pages oh I and so some of
it I think of all the pages you know
let's say 10 to 20 or they had to
reproduce from you know within house but
the rest it was this massive project
where they tracked down through
collectors people that have bought pages
original artwork 2-pound returned and
put out this gigantic honking [ __ ]
book it is a gorgeous piece I have to
get I saw somebody on Instagram with
that and I was like have to get this and
I'm good I have to get the Miller as a
jelly daredevil born again the big one
what do you mean the big a one years ago
I'm an accountant yeah I think I think
sour sauce yeah like little comic okay
yeah the masa chellie pages is [ __ ]
good you got one useful information yeah
there's how do I get more
yeah I know like I've been it's one of
the things that I like every once awhile
go look at anything but like I should
get this right and you and it's not
where you're like any down things but
it's like oh my god like if it doesn't
get bought someone won't think to make
another one one day I thought whenever
I'm going to store and actually like DC
stuff for my eyes like I'm gonna buy and
even if it's like Kitty step and
Jennifer's like lime like because they
need nobody buys it they won't make it
again this is a Black Manta doll but
nobody was making that when I was a
child needs that my play on this the
books are called young DC's young animal
line this is the book you could buy
tomorrow don't growl we're almost done 6
mm-hmm
what is it 6 6 Jim - there de la there's
a Janet all for the first session 6 p.m.
[ __ ] bring addicted then oh [ __ ] and
makes the 3 & 1 and the best part of
comics is when they go sit down
where's your favorite comic I mean
obviously a big dude chillin and back
when you were working the shop what was
the one of you recommends everybody what
was your religion oh I'm sure I got
really into the crow I'm playing and I'm
still looking like from the legs like
when it first instance yeah well I got
like no or leghul second print was in
the book oh yeah I Brisbane Hospital
back when it was a lot of favorites but
yeah yeah man that blew me away like the
crow is what is wonderful but that book
was I remembered by my mother's caliber
yeah caliber I am buying it off the rack
and grandma hmm the children the first
appearance is in one of those caliber
presents yeah gotta represent for the
Tim vigil cover yeah because you collect
a foul yeah I sure did I was 14 ah
that's in it I'm trying to think what
were the other big titles of that moment
man oh my god we were clothed me I'm at
the end it was dim and then I'm trying
to be winning I mean role playing a lot
I was playing a lot RPGs so it's not
beyond Dungeons & Dragons sounds like
you were playing yeah we were playing
everything
yeah Alexander that members good yeah we
did it in the store and the store wasn't
bit like it was historical metropolis
comic longer oh yeah log on log on but
we're still friends and
you know I talked to those guys we had
to get together a year half ago we all
got together and eager to do it we did
not know what the [ __ ] yeah go to Marion
they're in the book put a new Explorer
like the shop is in the book
oh my job how awesome are you I'm
screwed it really transforms me another
experience
no girl there you go that's Chris he
passed away of cancer last year
here maybe a blog we put in the Edward
behind the counter and then you have the
Scott Pat Deena and so I wanted that to
be the nerve center of Danny because
that's kind of the nerve center right
not a mystery yeah yeah the street yeah
that's where I met Danny was in that
place in this culture in that problem so
what did you do give the artist here's
pictures Pat the owner he had photos Wow
and he had actually had like something
he must have made like a infographic of
it or a 3d it made something like that
and it's like this is what it looked
like it was exact so that's exactly what
seemingly
the air conditioner look at the window
unit put them yeah yeah anybody who so
do you run into in life since the days
of lik metropolis none of them have you
ever run into people like used to Sunday
my comics no I don't I don't think so
so with the be real that would recognize
you don't be like we I don't feel like
we stole a lot of comic you know past
the owner he was amazing he tolerated
all of us and I really don't feel just
showed a lot of it's like I just want
hovering I feel a deployed place for
work there's a lot of gigs in there like
playing be a whip
and what is so if would somebody who
went there be like nobody should I tell
people ah that's deep I don't I think
only the people that were attached to
the place I felt like God or something
and doing it right goddamn it
memorializing all that brought you to
comics in the pages overcome is you know
it's important scene is important book
to me
that scene led me to comics we can use
yeah let me to do control ready dude
cool yeah did have you do you are you
you must have met many times of the year
spring mores yes we and you told him um
divert them to give you any advice he
did he said and he said find the new
weird and that was the best advice he
was like the stuff I was doing 20 years
ago that was really weird at the time
like a lot of that stuff isn't its
mainstream now so he's like you have to
find the new weird um so I just actually
started to do that and I discovered
inflation and all these other pretty
amazing things that I'd never heard of
before
yeah that's also a great t-shirt yeah I
believe we're done Amanda were still on
a treehouse pretty much yeah he's been
amazingly supportive I know how personal
do patrol examine and certain characters
like Danny the street you know really
important to him and so I made sure to
ask him questions when it needed to like
hey we're getting from them and I'm not
telling anybody but sure you are you're
not only a great creator of a great time
I'm a yeah if I like something I'm
really I try to be good to the thing
that's good to me so put that off what
are you writing on Baba's I got jolly
good that's one of the great things
about comics is that at least we do to
do it right realize that I work in this
book I created this book and somebody
would do it after me but some image of
comics yeah and the sort of goodwill to
the guys taking over after you yeah yeah
kind of wonderful it is that I'm so glad
you brought that up there's like this
kind of sometimes in the best case in
there and this is kind of unspoken
camaraderie that happens we're like I'm
excited to one day pass this over to
somebody else
I would I would love it to be seamless
or and even if they're doing something
radically different like like I think
Paul copper burg helped grant get into
his run Grant had asked he had some
requests work for Paul hmm and he had
said I could you do this could you kill
this cat species shut him up for his own
people want to jump to him when he
jumped in and I
would be glad to do that for another
writer the the we love comics continues
to turn live as it was done for you so
you can do it for somebody else
the book is out if you're watching this
on Monday tomorrow if you're watching
there's any dead look to Monday or
Tuesday and it's out now which is
[ __ ] make it sure to buy it first six
issues I'm going to dive in dude I'm
going to keep this they started keeping
ass they also brought us uh towels I
look like this flexing California
collagen here at the beach town um you
are living the goddamn dream I really am
and you're doing is proud to it's not
just like you're living dream and you're
burning it in your wake and being like
Halle [ __ ] the dream you're doing it
right thank you honoring it and I'm
trying
Oh Debbie good heart I'm trying thank
you young animal line through hard way
he's in comics using your head and heart
still carry on
still carry on I'm going for you Justin
oh my god like it's a mess on the page
matter I believe I said that before
not to you said that thank you
drug war criminals hey thanks for having
done nothing [ __ ] job from fat man
I'm Batman
I've been Kevin Smith I've been mark
barnard and he's been drugged Wayne come
back next episode and see at least two
of us same bat-time same bat-channel
SModcast comp or you took the guns last
Kevin Smith super troll okay
so one thing I had clarify is that West
End game did not make the Washington
supplement for the RPG with Mayfair
games I remember it as we finished
podcast I want to Bri know that I got my
[ __ ] in order how how adorable is that
he wanted you to know for sure that he
knew that Mayfair did that and West End
doesn't start wars game anyway is one
that yes that was a good game they're
both good games if you were sitting out
there and you were about to type in the
comment section you don't know [ __ ]
about RPG you literally had to destroy
your fingers away from the kids idea
well done here this is them sort of
record with Geron way